Thank You Steven it's great honor to be
here let's continue the theme of energy
as the previous speaker has mentioned
about and I'm a hardcore electrical
engineer so not only we worry about you
know dollars we also worry about keeping
the lights on so this is a joint work
with cumulatively with three of my
present and former students yung Chen
she's now a PJM mangu she's now teaching
at Arizona State and Tom who is now a
PhD student and also professor Nick
Ferris for NYU Abu Dhabi and professor
Pia Kumar who is sitting here so all the
fun things that you hear about the grid
creating rich dynamics on the system we
got more and more uncertain renewable
generation that's much much less
predictable you got electric vehicles
you've got flexible demand much much
less predictable everybody is talking
about parktronic interfaces because all
these new gadgets are interfacing from
the grid using Parekh Tronics that
effectively means that it reduces this
effective system inertia so more
dynamics and countries like China or
India are putting together long distance
high-voltage AC or high-voltage DC lines
over thousands of miles connecting
remote areas together
much strong coupling right so I think
there's a traditional way of model-based
analysis and operation it's going to be
rendered perhaps less valid and there is
a great increasing need for which is the
theme of this program for real-time
learning and decision making what are
the good news the good news is that in
the past decade or so not only in this
country but throughout the world people
have invested billions of dollars into
sensors and these sensors are just you
know great resources for us to gang with
ability onto what's going on in the grid
I just give you a couple of examples and
the first example is the so called the
deployment of the phasor measurement
unit for the outsiders just think about
it as a GPS synchronized fast sensor
that is sampling at 60 Hertz now what's
the state of the art before that it was
a unsynchronized static measurement
every 4 seconds so we're talking about
orders of magnitude improvement and more
importantly with a precise timestamp
that's very important because we're
talking about the large grid once you
have the time you know synchronized you
can then put pieces together right and
these are measuring you essentially
seven electrical variables real power
reactive power voltage magnitude voltage
phase angle current magnitude current
phase angle and frequency seven okay we
already have more than two thousand in
North America more than two thousand
China India is going to invest about ten
billions or so into it in the next
twenty years
smart meters that's close to your
households everybody here looking living
in the Bay Area get it replaced in the
past five years so again for the
outsiders what if smart meters
these are 15-minute time interval remote
readers and remote controllers to the
households level right so instead of
doing monthly sending an electrical
check on your backyard now you can do it
online real-time okay
so in this country we already have more
than 65 million and similar numbers are
also true everywhere in the world so all
of these sensors give us enormous amount
of visibility into what's going on right
so this is just a snapshot of what you
can see now on the real grid we're not
talking about toy examples we're talking
about real eastern US interconnection
all the way from Florida to up to Canada
so the what you see here is the coloring
is basically the frequency measurement
at a particular location on the eastern
grid so as you can see the grid was
never at steady state it's always
changing always oscillating
right it's almost like people are
breathing in and out in and out and that
the breathing is basically reflecting
the frequency going up and down and
that's also a good indicator of the
supply demand imbalances across
different regions now it sounds like a
fun video so okay we put the sensors we
can see that what's wrong with that well
this is kind of a Pinay example which is
just showing that people are just
randomly turning on and off the lights
and doing the usual things but there are
less benign examples which I'm going to
show you in the next slide that's a real
problem that happened in this part of
the country on the western side of the
interconnection one generator up in
Alberta started some oscillations 20
megawatts
no big deal but somehow thousands miles
away it created its first resonance
oscillation up and down for 200
megawatts between California and Oregon
nobody had expected okay and this 200
megawatt back and forth we're talking
about 200 megawatt right the city of San
Francisco is less than I don't know 100
megawatts right so so this huge swing
created system Island and blackout and
nobody has actually thought about that
and it's very difficult to pinpoint
where it happened because it was
thousands of miles away upping our
burner okay so these are some real
problems we need to deal with so that's
kind of the theme of my talk which is
now utilizing this streaming data that
is sending now to the system s control
center is it possible to make some near
real-time data driven decision making
more concretely what I mean is that can
we know what's happening can we
visualize those these are high
dimensional streaming data power system
engineers are high school graduates
which may not know all these details
things so can we visualize that can we
do anomaly detection can we classify
what kind of anomaly it is and can we
pinpoint where it happened and then more
importantly is really something can be
done can I do some adaptive demand
response or generation read dispatch or
any kind of a correct
to measure that I can think about so I'm
going to focus on the blue colored
points in this particular talk okay so
what is force oscillation it's kind of a
nice refresh thing back to where they
undergraduate classes you can think
about the power system is a large high
dimensional high order dynamical system
and you got inputs from all the
generators and all the demands right
think about this some perturbation
that's coming from the generation say
there is a solar fluctuation up and down
and that fluctuation somehow meet the
internal modes some internal modes of
the system right and that internal modes
of the system created this sustained
oscillation right which are not
necessarily well damped out and that's
kind of the situation that you saw in
the preview see in the previous slide
right so this is kind of the situation
that we need to deal with we want to
detect them we want to classify that we
want to localize them we want to make
sure to get rid of that so let's first
talk about how to detect them so one of
the first challenge that for this type
of streaming analytics for the power
grid is this high dimensionality I'm
just kind of giving you a conceptual
example which hopefully kind of make the
point let's say even we only have a
hundred PM you in the western US right
this is already a much much lower number
than we saw and let's say they just
measure on our 30 Hertz time interval
sampling rate let's say they just each
PM you they measure 20 measurements okay
this already translates to you know
60,000 data points a snapshot and five
billion data points a day right these
kind of a streaming data sending to the
control center it is very difficult for
a traditional power engineer to make
sense out of them and to see what's
going on and these calls for the need
for you know the first thing we do is to
do some kind of a dimensionality
reduction and the u.s. power grid is
protected under the US Energy Act
called a critical confidential
infrastructure which means that those
data those measurements are typically
not to be shared in the public
fortunately at Texas A&M we have very
good working relationship with almost
all the system operators and companies
so we have got about four terabytes
worth of such pmu data that we can
actually take a look at from the real
world so that's one thing we tested on
all three interconnection in the u.s.
Eastern Western and Texas what you see
here is basically the first thing we did
which is we take all the raw
measurements of the PMU data we get the
principal component analysis of this pmu
data and what you see here is horizontal
axis is the number of principal
components the y axis is the cumulative
variations from all these measurements
so you can roughly think about them as
the cumulative amount of information
stored in the top X number of principal
components so sorry for the not very
visible but basically the point is that
for a large system 200 P mu 300 PM use
you don't need that much or the top
three or four principal components has
already accumulated more than 99.5
percent of the cumulative variance that
is happening on the grid and we're
talking about real data with all the
noise communication areas a packet
dropped and all that right so that's
kind of a very good news to us because
there we can think about much better
ways of streaming analytics to the
system operators and that's exactly what
we did force first here which is we try
to visualize them by showing the scatter
plot which is basically recast of the
original mesh P mu measurements from
this high dimensional original sample
space into the say a sub space organized
by the top two or top three principal
components that we are cut right and
because of that the the notion of time
is lost so we use the color coding to
show the evolution of time the more
towards the blue is more towards the
past right so as you can see already
there are some kind of interesting
observations we can find
when the system was under normal
conditions or near normal conditions
they actually reside all the data points
reside in extremely small concentrated
subspace in his blue color and
immediately now post actually we knew
that there was a generator tripping
immediately when the generator tripped
we started to see these points deviate
from them so how fast we slowed the
points into the data part we throw them
into them at the centering rate of 30
Hertz right so we're basically seeing
that almost in near-real-time that there
is some event happening and what you see
on the right hand side is corresponding
to a sustained oscillation that we
observed in the Bonneville Power
Administration area which is up up being
a Washington so so you can see already
one can develop these near real-time
streaming analytics to do event
detection and this is just a recap and
kind of a nicer view of what happened
based on some of the texas data we
obtained okay so so we actually did a
little bit syria out of that which is
basically trying to say on online
streaming fashion what do we do how do
we do this we come
we constantly compute based on a moving
horizon of window the PMU measurements
and compute the pca and that's a very
efficient computation we obtain the
pilot pmu based on the top two or top
three principal components right
remember principal components are linear
combination of all the p.m. use but we
want to kind of relate them to a
physical PM u so we kind of try to
indicate what are the pilot PM use and
based on these pilot PM use will do a
streaming comparison of the other PM u
measurements based on the correlation
and the actual measurements we obtain
from these non-pilot PM use if there's
error is small things are okay if error
is big things are not okay simple as
that right so this way we are able to
detect this type of forced oscillation
or sustained oscillation within a few
samples of the streaming PM u data
points whereas
conventional state-of-the-art method is
usually relying on single channel or
selected a few channels sort of a
frequency domain analysis which is a
kind of orders of magnitude slower so
that's kind of a interesting finding
that we got so that's about so that was
kind of about how to do detection we
also have done something wrong once we
know there's something happening you can
classify them so is it an oscillation
this is a generator tripping or is a
line tripping and more interestingly we
began to investigate into the next
question which is suppose we knew that
this oscillation are happening now the
generators needs to be pinpointed the
system operator want to find out where
it occurred so that's kind of a more
recent work and I'm going to show you
that in the next 10 minute or so so
let's say why it's localization an
interesting problem so basically the
problem is as follows how do I determine
based on all the measurements I could
tell right the source the the the
problematic generator or the problematic
input that create that sustained
oscillation or forced oscillation that
sounds like a intuitive problem right
why do you need a PhD to work on this
you can ask a kid so I have a
two-year-old we go to the sea we throw a
stone into the water start oscillating
so how do I detect the source of
oscillation very simple I just look at
which one if I have the measurement
wherever is the biggest magazine
measurement that should pinpoint to the
source of oscillation right not true in
the power system says I'll show you some
counter examples sorry right exactly and
also if I have this precise time
synchronized measurement
can I just compare the beginning of the
change or the phase angle there
whichever is starting to change the
first should pinpoint to the source of a
look oscillation right
and it turns it out that is not true
either so what I show you here is that
the red curves are the measurements
nearest to the source of the oscillation
and all the other colored curves are the
non source measurements
so both conjectures were shown to be
wrong
you cannot rely on magnitude you can not
rely on the face angle leading factor as
an indicator either larger fluctuation
that's basically shows the oscillation
mode yeah yes so this is something I
learned again with talking to Kumar
Kumar that's something you know
different context
you know people work on these civilians
videos and when you have a bunch of
streaming civilians videos how do you
kind of separate the person walking in
the video from the background right and
that's a classical problem so a block
people have worked on that the key idea
is that you try to decompose this
measurement sequence into sort of two
pieces right one piece kind of
represents this unchanging but kind of a
highly correlated spatial measurements
which is kind of a deep background and
the other one corresponds to the sort of
a more sparse that it's kind of a relate
to the occurrence of this abnormality
which is the people the person walking
so we think that the problem of
localizing this type of forced
oscillation can be also thought about in
a similar fashion one can think about
this low rank matrix that we observed
earlier as indicator of the general
trend that is happening across entire
grid so for example this would be the
dominant dynamics across the entire
eastern US whereas the
source of oscillation so that's another
kind of a piece of engineering
experience you know none of the two
events you know power system has a lot
of events happening but our conjecture
is that none of two events will happen
exactly at the same time right let's say
even you have a lightning strike here
and then a tree falling down there they
never happen exactly the same time so at
any given snapshot the hypothesis is
that it will be very few if not only one
events happening right and that's sort
of a these sparsity matrix which
represents that will try to decompose
them into this low ranked part and the
sparsity part and then whichever the
sparsity nonzero element the hypothesis
that would pinpoint to the source of the
forced oscillation okay
that's kind of the problem formulation
we get a streaming pmu data samples we
would like to decompose them into a low
ranked part now we can talk about what
is our and what is P and the end then
the sparse part right that's the
original problem formulation but it
turns out on this one you can do some
methods for example alternating
projections give you some local minimum
but it never kind of a guarantee is to
converge and we don't exactly know R and
P we can use some engineering judgment
to say ok R is equal to 3 and P is equal
to 2 and we can get some solution but we
have a little bit of a trouble getting
the convergence in some times so instead
we actually go to the right hand side
formulation which is trying to say that
we'd like to minimize the this X which
is the sparsity matrix such that a
nuclear norm of the difference between y
and x plus the norm one of x with some
weighting factor lambda this one is
minimized ok and this is a convex
property we don't need to know the R and
P and there are state-of-the-art
efficient algorithms to solve it for
example we use these augmented
Lagrangian multipliers methods to solve
it
so what we find what we find is that
this is a particular synthetic network
which has 68 buses and 16 generators so
we did a lot of different resonance
studies we basically randomly perturb at
different sources of generators and then
see what will cause some forced
oscillation in the grid and we ask if we
have the measurement at every single bus
as the PMU measurements could we
localize where these this oscillation
occurred so the result is that out of
the 44 resonance cases we were able to
pinpoint forty forty successfully there
are four cases that we the result were
not 100% accurate first of all that's
kind of a very good we present this to
the real system operators they were
shockingly surprised and then we look
into these four cases that we were wrong
and we want to find out what caused this
wrong
for example the true source is in
generator three but our algorithm was
telling us it should be in generator two
so that kind of interesting if you pay
attention to this network a little bit
as far as the impact is concerned these
two generator almost has identical
impact to the great dynamics they are of
the same order of size they have almost
the same logical distance to the
anything to the total rest of the system
so the good news is that even though for
the wrong cases it also effectively
narrows down the search space for us so
we know that okay once we have this
algorithm we can kind of a narrow down
the areas of search at least for for
photo for the problems that we are
looking at right so that's kind of a
another interesting finding we're still
kind of a pushing forward this for for
for larger scales and also to do some
interesting yes
what you mean by there's a resonance
case is that generate a generator began
to began to inject a period periodical
input which causes a resonance on the
grid detect part detection part is to
utilize just the low rank property of
the PMU data and then to run the pca and
to obtain this measurement error to
obtain this error between measurement
and the projection if that error is big
so that's the section okay so I think
you're asking about between detection
and localization there is a middle stage
right something like that in the
practical setting what will happen is
that this algorithm could narrow down
these regions Alberta region say okay
this is the place where it seems to be
having something wrong and then
engineering judgment and you know
engineering experience will kicking and
then say okay looks like this generator
is creating some kind of a weird
oscillatory behavior right so that's the
corrective measure part yeah so this is
not the end of the story you know you
can localize this but then you need to
also do some corrective measures and
perhaps before the corrective measure
one needs to confirm that's what you
mean
okay so no big deal two ideas one is
that we utilize dimensionality reduction
for anomaly detection and we've kind of
a also utilize this robust pca to
explore the sparsity of the PMU
measurements to localize anomaly events
such as forced oscillation and there are
many many opportunities for streaming
and with analytics for example you know
cyberattack is a big topic these days
and can you do some kind of a dynamic
watermarking to do detect such a cyber
attacks instead of just the physical
anomalies
the answer is potentially yes people
worry about p.m. you've data quality 15%
of the PMU data is labeled as wrong or
bad data big number right 15% so can you
do some kind of a data quality
correction the answer is yes you can
also leverage this idea of low ranked
not only we have pmu data we also have
smart meter data and customer data can
we do streaming analytics for customers
we have done some pilot studies on sort
of this coupon based demand response
also generating some interesting results
now if we have individual customers can
I kind of build up a portfolio of
individual customers and do some
streaming analytics for demand response
market on hosting level and one of kamar
students has work on that dynamic system
modeling which potentially could be used
for closing a group around customers and
can we do kind of a real-time data
driven says if I have lots of these
scenarios in the past can I produce a
tunable risk level dispatch and
optimization or market clearing and also
we have worked a little bit on this
scenario approach utilizing the real
data with some guarantees on the level
of risk of violation so I think there's
a lot of interesting opportunities I
think people in this room could
certainly teach the power engineers a
lot about you know what can be done
it's a great forum to to to talk about
these problems and opportunities so with
that I thank you for your attention and
be happy to take any questions so for
both of these questions aren't you
essentially not including the dynamics
wouldn't it be better if you had the
diet write down the dynamics so for the
first part the theory part actually
utilizes the dynamics models to show
that why this data-driven work would
work let's say linearize the dynamics
write down a measurement map and then do
the pca on the observability granion
which basically tells you which modes
are instead of just looking at the time
we did that also we have two kind of
observations number one is that it's
much slower and number two is that these
modes because of operating condition
changes is kind of hard to track there
is not a single linearize dynamical
model to start with so it's kind of
always changing as the system operating
conditions changes and then the third
point I want to say is that even this
simplistic approach seems to be working
quite well but but I think there's an
untapped potential in connecting perhaps
to some kind of a courser model of
system dynamics with this kind of
data-driven approach to say something
insightful structure then maybe you can
turn it into an inverse problem perhaps
yes and people have kind of a tried that
also yeah yeah yeah and yeah that's
interesting idea
so basically as far as the result is
concerned right now again we are still
in progress but all those results we
have so far have either one non zero or
two non zeros so we kind of just label
either the one of them or two of them as
these sources and then we just do some
further engineering judgment and
narrowing down so we kind of we did both
in a sense the the measurements that we
obtained is kind of already showing this
electromechanical kind of oscillations
on the grid and the low rank property
essentially indicates that perhaps this
is well justified by the swing equation
dynamics on the system on large systems
so in some sense it's sort of the space
mass spect
is is is illustrated through this large
high dimensional data the temporal
aspect I think what it indicate is that
this type of pmu measurements illustrate
the dominant modes on the swing
equations but not necessarily the entire
rich dynamics that you would have
written for example thousands of
dynamical equations those are not
necessarily represented in these thirty
Hertz or 60 Hertz measurements
okay
[Applause]